con sorpresa fue tomada en México la
noticia de que el Cartel del Golfo
entregó a quienes habrían sido los
supuestos secuestradores de los
ciudadanos estadounidenses en Matamoros
cinco sujetos fueron dejados maniatados
al lado de una cartulina en la que la
organización criminal se deslinda del
secuestro dice que estos individuos
actuaron por su cuenta desobedeciendo
las reglas del Cártel y ofreciendo una
disculpa esto se da en medio de una
creciente disputa entre legisladores
republicanos de Estados Unidos con el
gobierno de López Obrador Porque estos
legisladores plantean desplegar a las
fuerzas armadas estadounidenses para
combatir a los cárteles mexicanos a
quienes llaman a considerar como
terroristas el presidente López Obrador
ha tenido una dura respuesta a estos
planteamientos asegurando que se trata
de propuestas politiqueras que obedecen
a la campaña electoral en Estados Unidos
y que son falta de respeto a la
soberanía de México algo que jamás sería
permitido en este país y es en este
contexto que se dio este jueves un
encuentro entre la consejera de
seguridad de la Casa Blanca Elizabeth
con el propio López Obrador el canciller
Marcelo ebrard y miembros de su gabinete
tras la cual tras esta reunión según lo
informado por el secretario Marcelo
ebrard se pactó una estrategia conjunta
inédita de combate al fentanilo se
acordó también llevar a cabo una campaña
de concientización entre los jóvenes
para alertar de los daños por el consumo
de esta droga y también se habría
negociado incrementar el personal que se
dedica a combatir el tráfico de este
estupefaciente